- Hi, everyone.
Sal Khan here from Khan Academy.
Welcome to the homeroom live stream.
We have a very exciting guest today,
CEO of AT&T, John Stankey's here.
So start putting your
questions on Facebook
and wherever you're watching it,
and I will try to get as many
of them as possible to John,
lot to talk about.
But before we jump into that,
I will give my standard announcements.
Reminder to everyone that
we are not for profit.
So if you can make your way
to Khanacademy.org/donate,
and if you're in a position to do so,
please think about making a donation.
It really, really makes a difference.
I also want to give a
special shout out to several
organizations that have stepped
up really over the years,
but especially during COVID,
when they realized that
the world was more dependent
on Khan Academy than ever.
But also our costs have gone
up, our traffic had increased,
we were trying to put more
content, support programs,
training for teachers and parents.
So special thanks to Bank
of America, Google.org,
AT&T, fastly, and
Novartis for that support.
It's really, really been a big deal.
But if you're in a position to
do so all of y'all listening,
please think about continuing to support
because we continue to need
help in filling our gap.
Also want to remind folks that
a version of this live stream
is available wherever
you get your podcasts
at Homeroom with Sal the podcast.
With that, I'm really excited
to introduce our guest,
John Stankey, the CEO of a
small startup called AT&T.
John, thanks for joining us.
- Sal, thanks for having me,
and you know what big fans
we are in the work you do at Khan Academy,
at AT&T, so it's a real treat for me
to be part of the curriculum today.
- Well, no, and I do have to thank y'all.
I mean, it is a really big
deal the work that y'all do.
I mean, on a bunch of
levels that we're gonna talk
a lot about things like internet
access and digital divide,
because obviously we can't do our work
and reach the folks who need
it most without that existing.
But y'all over the years,
not just during COVID,
have been big supporters of Khan Academy,
and that really means a lot.
So everyone listening,
if you're able to benefit
from Khan Academy,
it's AT&T and organizations like it
that really allow us to do this work.
But John, maybe a good place to start.
You are relatively new in the job at AT&T,
AT&T is a storied institution
for maybe the younger people
who didn't know, it's not a startup,
it's a very well established.
What was kind of your thought process
as you've taken the role,
and as you're taking this,
I would call AT&T is kind
of one of the institutions
of America or the world.
How are you viewing that?
- Well it's interesting you
use the analogy startup,
and I know you kind of did it
in jest, but the reality is,
well, it's a storied
institution that's been around
for a very, very long time.
Just about every line of
business that we operate in
right now is in a major state
of transition and transformation.
And so even an established
company like AT&T,
I think there's so many
different industries
and so many large established businesses
because of not only COVID,
but what's just going on
in the economy in general,
that are all undergoing
some pretty rapid and significant change,
and we're no exception to that.
And as a result of that,
while it's a big company,
and we have several large
lines of businesses,
each one of those inside
the company is going through
its own transition and transformation.
And so it's a very exciting
time to come into this role.
It's a bit of a humbling
time as you indicated,
which so many of the
things that we do right now
in this COVID environment
are dependent on the networks
and the infrastructure that we provide.
And I reminded that of the bad everyday,
sometimes positive comments
coming back from our customers,
talking about how they're
surviving and living their lives
and doing the things that they must do
because of the services we provide.
But also, I sometimes
hear about that moment
when the service doesn't
work on a given day,
and just how significant
an interruption is
to somebody's wellbeing
and their daily existence
if that happens, and
puts a lot of pressure
on the organization.
But I've been really
pleased with how overall
the businesses perform, how
our employees stepped up
to ensuring services work
during this critical time,
and I couldn't be more happy
about the new relevance
that I think people have
found in our services
in this moment.
- And where do you see your focal point?
I mean, given what's going on in COVID,
you've written a lot about the need for
solving the digital divide issue.
Obviously y'all have
been key actors in this.
Y'all have really been doing
great things when it comes to
getting communities
through this COVID period,
especially communities that
did not have internet access,
making it far more accessible.
What are the programs that
you've done in the short term?
And how are you thinking
about this long term?
How do we solve the digital divide issue?
- You know, it's interesting
because in some regards,
there's that old analogy of the old house
that needs a lot of structural work,
that sometimes you put a little
bit of plaster or spackling
over cracks to hide them.
And I would say maybe pre-COVID,
that might've been the
state of internet access
in the United States in some regards.
Some very robust and
capable wireless networks
have been built.
And many individuals
were getting their access
to the internet and
frankly, living their life
in a pretty okay fashion with wireless
as their answer to the problem.
And they made a basic utility
and value call and said
for what I need to do in my life,
and the things I need access for,
having a smartphone is adequate,
and that's given that
I've gotta worry about
putting food on the table
or going to see the doctor next month.
It was a luxury to think about having both
a wireless connection
and a fixed connection,
so many people chose not to do that.
And as a result of COVID,
I think what we've seen is,
well that might've worked before,
somebody's at home and is
having to live on the internet
24 hours a day, sit in a
classroom, watch teacher,
keep their attention on
maybe a multi-screen format
with a speaker and other
content showing up.
There's limitations to
that three and a half
or four inch screen that
everybody depends on
and carries around in
their pocket everyday.
And there's limitations in the robustness
of a wireless network
compared to fixed networks.
So we've really seen that this dynamic of
the 17 million students
that don't have access
to fixed broadband becomes a
problem in this environment.
And when you think about all the work that
companies, organizations, sorry,
like yourselves have done,
in building great curriculum
that can be consumed at home,
you really need that
robust infrastructure.
You need the ability to
sit with a larger screen
and have an experience.
And so, we're looking at this twofold.
One is, there's a public policy issue
that needs to be dealt with,
and we're leaning into that at AT&T.
In fact, I'm starting
to orient the company
and all of the work we're doing
around our charitable giving,
what we're trying to
do in policy advocacy,
how we're engaging our employees
and their working communities,
to start working on the issues that effect
those 17 million students,
and probably 24 million
households that really don't have
that robust fixed access to the internet.
And that's policy shifts
that need to occur.
In some cases, we've got a lot of subsidy
that are part of our tax structure,
that maybe is not being directed
as effectively as it could.
In some cases, maybe we need
new ways to subsidize service
for those who can't afford to pay for it,
and trying to get that
policy structure proper.
I would also tell you,
there's certain things
that we need to do to
facilitate the ecosystem.
We know that just providing
discounted access isn't enough.
We provide $10 a month access
for low-income households,
is one of the services we provide at AT&T.
We found that wasn't enough
because many homes don't have
access to the tablet or the
laptop computer that they need
to really use that access
in an effective way.
So putting vehicles in place
where we started to donate
money into entities that helped solve
that complete ecosystem
of what a household needs
for distance learning and
access to the internet.
And then we want this to be
done in a sustainable fashion.
And we think that you need
good robust infrastructure.
And while we're continuing
to invest aggressively
in the core parts of our business,
the core parts of our network,
and we'll be making some
announcements here shortly
about stepping up fiber investment.
Look, there's parts of the United States
that just aren't that dense.
And as a result of that,
we need to think about
policy that supports
access into rural areas
with adequate broadband to be
able to do most of the things
that many households take for granted
in suburban, urban areas
and starting to try to drive
policy adoption in that regard.
- I'm curious, I actually
I wanna double click on
each of those, but on that last point,
just kind of the telecom nerd inside of me
wants to make sure I understand thing.
For everyone listening, you
can dig up kind of the ground
and put fiber in it, which is
a very expensive proposition.
And then that can get
really good quality access
to a lot of folks.
But to your point, if
you're in some rural place,
it could be very cost prohibitive
to make sure that every,
let's call it farm, has
fiber running through it.
But you think that there's
ways to do wireless access
that could get us close
or have the sufficiently
high bandwidth and reliability
to meet those folks' needs.
- If you think about it from
a public policy perspective,
you go back decades in the
United States had a policy
that it felt like
everybody should get access
to the telephone network.
And that universal access
construct was established
many years ago with overt
policy around subsidy,
around how do we make sure
that even the farmhouse
in a rural area was able
to get on the network.
But if everybody paid their
true cost of that service,
there's no way that farmhouse
ever would have been connected.
The cost would have been so prohibitive,
nobody would've ever built those
small twisted copper
pair wires to that home.
So we average pricing
across the United States,
with the deliberate
policy approach to ensure
we eventually got 98% of US households
onto the telephone network.
We're at that same
moment for the internet.
And when we think about
solving that problem,
if that's the case, there's
probably going to be
some degree of subsidy that comes in,
which may mean public
money, taxpayer money.
And I don't think the answer
to that is that we wanna go
and overbuild and have
fiber out to a farmhouse,
where it might cost 10
times the amount it does
in a suburban or rural area.
But can we get the benefits
of getting on the internet
with adequate bandwidth and
maybe a lower cost alternative,
maybe something that's
only two times as expensive
is what it might take in
a urban or suburban area,
but still get most of the
benefits of being on the internet?
And so one of the policy
positions we believe is important
is a technology agnostic point of view,
get the most effective way
to get the right amount
of bandwidth out to every home.
And in some cases, to your
point, it might be using
the latest technology around
wireless services like 5G.
But in some cases, the answer
may be a different technology,
possibly low Earth orbiting satellites,
and what's coming up
with Leo capabilities,
and that might be the more effective way
to get to some highly rural households.
And in some areas, there
may be a opportunity
is infrastructure's being
deployed for power, electricity
to also piggyback fiber in there.
The point is, you wanna
do the right thing,
at the right time, and the right house,
but not overspend taxpayer
money to gold plate things
that ultimately don't
need to be gold plated.
And we're trying to
provide some frameworks now
as we work with policymakers
on understanding where those
cutoffs are and how we
think about that deployment
of infrastructure moving forward.
- And quick technical question,
what's a Leo capability?
- So if you think about
satellite technology
that's been in place for many decades,
typically you put a satellite
way up high in orbit,
and it sits over a particular
part of the United States
and it's geostationary, and it follows
that particular part of
the geography constantly.
With Leo, these satellites
are much smaller.
- Oh, lower, I see.
- Much less expensive.
You put them up much
lower in the atmosphere.
They don't last as long,
but because they're so
much less expensive,
you can cover a much broader
part of the United States
with allowing them to work in
a non-geostationary fashion
and circle the globe.
And this new technology
opens up some opportunities
in some rural areas, that
weren't there before.
- And what you just described
is do it essentially saying,
do it fractional.
There's multiple ways of
getting internet access.
It could be fiber, it could be low Earth
orbiting satellites, it
could be 5G networks.
Is there a resistance of this?
Or is it just kind of we
have old laws on the books
that tend to be very focused
on landlines essentially?
- I think anytime you
get into a policy debate,
sometimes there are those
that are very knowledgeable
about a policy and very well-informed.
There are others who maybe
tend to gravitate more
to the soundbite.
And the soundbite is
everybody needs fiber.
And certainly in an ideal
world, would it be great
if every household in the United States
is connected to fiber?
Sure, that'd be wonderful.
But again, I don't think that's
the optimal use of public funds.
One of the things that people
like to go and reference
is they say, well look Korea,
how can so many homes in
Korea be connected to fiber?
Well, Korea actually isn't quite the size
of the United States.
They don't have square states
sitting in the middle of it
with a lot of open
territory and pasture land,
like the United States has.
So when you have a vertical society,
the ability to get fiber
into most households
is quite a bit different
than when you have
a more horizontal society
like the United States,
and you have to use
different solutions to that.
So I think those that are
informed and know the engineering
and the economics behind it,
understand that this needs
to be a technology agnostic
solution, that we need
to use all the tools
that we have in the toolbox
to address this effectively,
and frankly fast because
entrenching fiber everywhere
takes time, whereas
some wireless solutions
may get a lot of bandwidth
out fairly quickly because of
the nature of how that
infrastructure is deployed.
But I think it's just informing
folks with the fact-based,
so that everybody can have a
fully informed conversation about it.
- And one thing you've alluded to,
this kind of notion of
public private partnership.
And I think Telecom, growing up,
Telecom was one thing that
I always got confused about.
I was like, okay who's
digging those trenches?
Is that the government or is
that the AT&T's of the world?
Who is providing the subsidy?
Explain how that works.
My understanding it is, it's
private companies like AT&T,
that are putting the cost
behind the investment
by putting the infrastructure,
but the government provides
subsidies, discounts, incentives.
How does that interplay work?
- It's a complicated question
and there's a lot of layers to it.
I would tell you, if you think about it
at its most basic level,
the policy up to this point
in time in the United States,
which has largely been
a market based policy
for broadband infrastructure deployment
has actually worked quite well.
If you think about what's happened,
in coming into the pandemic,
with these dramatic increases in traffic,
people are not sitting around
talking about the fact that
you and I can conduct this session.
And at the same time, I'm still
not able to watch my Netflix
down the hall, that most of
that's working pretty well.
If you live in a urban or suburban setting
in the United States.
And so, policy has been really good
where markets are competitive,
driving that level of investment.
But there are places in
the United States where,
because of the density,
characteristics of how people live,
that market approach isn't quite enough
to incent that investment in broadband.
And there have been
subsidy models coming in
to try to incent companies
to go get some help
from different government funds to offset
the additional costs,
and then go in and build
in these territories.
And they've been successful to a degree,
but they haven't been quite as successful
as they need to be.
If there's still a large
number of rural households,
maybe 24 million non-broadband connected,
I bet 70, 80% of those are in rural areas
of the United States.
We clearly need to think about
a little bit different subsidy structure.
And I think this is where as
the government starts to deal
with things like
infrastructure deployment,
and maybe the early stages
of a Biden administration,
getting those incentives
right and explicit,
and setting companies like
AT&T or cable companies
or other telcos, to go in and
build that infrastructure.
That opportunity is in front of us.
We've had great success
with some of those programs
in the past.
Another subsidy program
that you may be familiar with is E-Rate.
E-Rate was targeted at
getting all of our schools
in the United States connected.
It was a deliberate
subsidy program that cause
for low cost infrastructure to
be deployed into every school
and library in the US, it's
been tremendously successful.
And everybody thought,
well check that box,
it's great, we've solved
the problem in education.
Until all of our students
started leaving the school house
and going home to learn.
Now the school was connected,
but we couldn't get to the end
points, the students at home.
And this is the next stage that
we kinda have to deal with.
- And given there's likely
to be multiple rounds
of stimulus going forward
over the next several months.
If what are the two or three policy levers
that you hope happens
over the next few months?
- I think we have to
think about the subsidy
and look at how it's
used today, and have it
kind of come together in
a more focused approach.
So there's $10 billion
over here in rural subsidy,
there's two and a half billion over here
in what we do for the next
version of E-Rate in schools,
there's what we do in
universal service structure
that comes in.
I think in some regards,
stepping back and saying,
if our goal is to get
everybody on the internet,
let's make sure we take
some of those programs,
aggregate them, and focus
them, that'd be one.
Two, look, if you're
going to have to go in
and do overt subsidy,
then we should think about
what the right mechanism is to do that.
And I think in an appropriations fashion,
Congress ought to be realistic about it.
Whereas today, some of these subsidies
are set up on dying infrastructure.
For example, the Universal Service Fund
that supports voice
service for access today,
is built on top of fixed
telephone line service.
Well, if fixed telephone
line services are doing this,
and there's fewer and fewer subscribers,
what happens to that subsidy pool?
It disappears eventually,
as everybody goes to
wireless services for voice.
So we need to step back,
make sure that those subsidy structures
are put on mechanisms
that are sustainable,
and that are fair to
the industry in total.
I don't think we should be
limiting our thought process
around how we attach that tax structure
to a particular product or service.
The internet has changed so
much how people make their money
and what services they use.
And we think about how the
edge providers, the Facebooks,
the Googles, the Amazons of the world,
who have benefited so much
from infrastructure deployment
and the capabilities of the internet,
maybe we need to think
about the base under which
we subsidize to come back
on a broader set of services
as we go forward, that are more relevant
for the going forward position,
and not based on the decades of old,
when we think about
voice telephone service.
So I think that's a dynamic
that we probably need
to come to grips with.
And then look, understanding
exactly where the problems are.
Believe it or not, a country
is as effective and capable
as United States, we actually
don't have really good data
and information around
where our problems are,
on how infrastructure's deployed.
AT&T has a point of view on
the markets that we serve,
in the homes that we handle,
but nobody really has a good picture of
what the United States
looks like in total,
because there are places
in the US we don't service.
We don't have infrastructure.
So knowing where we need
to put that subsidy,
have that policy change
to drive the right kind of
investment, and where the
market will take care of it,
is based on really good data.
And that data and funding
the ability to ensure
that we've got a good mapping
of what the circumstances are
in the United States
is another key element
I think of what happens to inform
really good policy moving forward.
- And what do you think
the odds are it'll happen?
You think people you're
talking to are aligned?
- You would think, I think
there's good probability
it can happen, although,
I'm the last person
to prognosticate on something
coming out of Washington.
It's oftentimes hard to
get the calculus of things.
But if you think about it today,
it's truly a bipartisan issue is,
many people you've had as
guests here will talk about,
everybody's in favor of education.
I think everybody understands
that it's a key issue
to equality, it's a key
issue to opportunity,
shouldn't be a Democratic
or a Republican issue,
it should just be, it's good
for our society as a whole.
So you start from that point of view.
Second thing I would
say is that the dynamics
kind of line up really well.
If you think about red states today,
many of those tend to be rural in nature.
They have an internet access problem.
And if you think about urban dynamics,
which tends to be more
Democrat stronghold,
they have an internet access problem.
So if the two sides can
get together and figure out
what we do in urban and what
we do to deal with rural,
then you would think you have
a natural coalition of folks
that wanna solve that problem.
Infrastructure has traditionally
been a bipartisan issue.
So, if there is something
that it would seem like
there might be an ability to
not only get some good policy done,
but figure out how we drive
spending in the right place
to come out of the COVID
dynamic, to equalize education,
to stimulate the economy,
to help telehealth.
It feels like there's enough
good news there for everybody,
that they should want to be
part of solving this problem.
- Yeah, I couldn't agree more.
And I do feel like the
energy behind this issue,
I've never seen more energy.
So fingers crossed.
In the remaining time here,
there's a bunch of
questions that have come in.
And some of them are just on your journey,
where Susanna Garcia Domingas
from YouTube is asking,
hi, Mr. Stankey, please
tell us about your journey
to become CEO, who are your heroes,
and how do you reboot or
re-energize to keep your life
in balance during these trying times?
How did you get to where you are?
And how do you handle it?
- It's a really good question.
And I'm always reticent to
answer this question because
and I tell my children this,
I grew up at a different time,
in a different United States,
in a different way of learning,
than what is the norm today.
And certainly, probably a
different social contract
and different set of
companies that were relevant
in the United States than what
a young aspiring professional
might encounter today.
And so, when somebody asks
me for advice, what I say is,
don't do it the way I did it
'cause that probably won't work anymore.
What I did is I ended up
spending a lot of time
and becoming quite deep in an industry,
and building expertise
in a particular industry.
I think I had some lessons
along the way when I was young
that taught me at an early
age the value of hard work,
and keeping your head down
and trying to do things well,
and if that happened, then eventually
you would be recognized for it.
And I was fortunate enough in some cases,
maybe even lucky enough,
to come along in my career
with a couple of individuals
that took an interest
in my career, that helped me out,
that gave me opportunities,
that allowed me to stretch
and maybe do some things that were beyond
what my capabilities
on paper might've said.
Lived up to those expectations,
and got succeeding
in increasing levels of
responsibility as a result of that.
Those lessons probably
aren't any different
for today's environment.
But what is different
is I went through the
traditional degree structure,
get an undergraduate degree,
have some pedigree in it, get
an opportunity to do a job,
maybe go get an advanced degree,
have some pedigree in it,
get an opportunity to do
something more significant.
I think that's so passe.
And it's not that I don't value education,
it's quite the opposite.
What I value is a lifelong
discipline to learning.
And the reality is, I think
the successful generations
moving forward, are
going to be individuals
who are very disciplined and
thinking about in everyday
as they wake up and every
month and every quarter
and every year, what are their objectives
for their own personal learning?
How are they going to build
a curriculum on a variety
of tools that are available
to them, to ensure that
they're dedicating their
time and energy to do that?
And they have to realize
that as this economy,
it is our environment
has become more global,
the internet has done that,
you're competing with
people all over the globe,
who everyday get up and have
access to some of the most
remarkable sets of
information they've ever had.
And if they're more motivated to get it,
digest it, and learn it than you are,
they're probably gonna be more competitive
professionally than you are.
And so you've gotta think about that
as you're your own chief learning officer.
You've gotta think about all the tools,
capabilities are available
to you, like the Khan Academy
and others, how you're
going to engage everyday
to learn more.
And if you do that, I think
you'll get more opportunity,
you'll get increasing
levels of responsibility,
and you'll keep your skills current,
as things are moving and changing.
And that, I think, is going
to be an incredibly important
part of people's success moving forward.
Balance, oh boy.
I always talk about it internally is
you have four dynamics in your life.
It's like a box
and you want that box
to be a perfect square.
And the reality is, very few
of us are ever really good at
making that box a perfect square.
It's your personal relationships
and those people that
are important to you,
family, close friends,
that's one side of it.
It's your personal
professional commitment,
what you do at work and
what satisfaction you get
out of that is one element of that box.
The third element of it is why
do you get up in the morning,
and what is your reason for being?
It might be a set of religious beliefs,
but you better be getting up
everyday and thinking about
the fact that there's some greater entity
you're serving, either your
coworkers, your fellow man,
or somebody that's more important
than you that drives you.
And the final and the
fourth area of that box
is really your physical wellbeing.
How healthy are you?
How well you take care of
this vehicle that you have
to get through life in?
Everybody would rather
probably drive a Porsche
than ride a scooter because
the Porsche performs better
and your body needs to be
a Porsche, not a scooter.
And so your job is to think
about your life everyday
across those four dimensions.
And when one side of that
square is out of balance,
work to get it into balance
or try to keep it balanced.
And I have to use a lot of discipline,
it's self-evaluation
across those four dynamics.
It's about setting limits.
Limits to how my professional life
creeps into my personal life.
How much time I reserve in a given day
to ensure that my body still functions.
What am I doing for my own mental renewal?
You have to be very disciplined
around thinking about
those things and not being shy about
building the coping mechanisms
and specifics to ensure that
you're spending time in
all four of those areas.
- Well, John, I could talk
to you for a few more hours
about actually each of these topics,
but you need to help
keep the nation's telecom
infrastructure going,
so that we can help the
nation keep learning.
Thank you so much for this
incredible conversation,
and thank you again for all of
your support over the years.
- Sal, thank you for everything
you do at the Khan Academy.
I'm more than happy to be affiliated,
and proud I could spend some
time with you this afternoon.
Thanks.
- Thank you so much, John.
Well everyone, thank you for joining.
Hopefully you enjoyed that
conversation as much as I did.
I find John to be an inspirational figure.
And I have light in my eyes
now, the sun has moved.
I really, hopefully we can
get him on in the future again
to talk about some of the
life work balance stuff,
which is I think,
something that we're all trying
to struggle with these days.
But anyway, thanks for joining.
A lot of important issues there.
Our next live stream will be on Thursday,
where we have a surprise guest.
We're going to actually announce
and meet the winner of the
breakthrough junior challenge,
which is this incredible
challenge where students
from around the world submit these videos
explaining new concepts
in math and science.
And the winner gets hundreds
of thousands of dollars
worth of prizes and scholarships.
So it'll be a pretty fun
conversation, I predict.
I will see you then.
(chimes)